that national security meeting started
not long ago and involved the deputies
inspectors for the organization of the
prohibition of chemical weapons arrived
in Syria today and tomorrow hope to be
on the ground in duma where the alleged
attack took place but it's not clear the
president intends to wait an emergency
meeting at the UN Security Council today
where US ambassador nikki Haley laid
blame for Syria's actions on Russia it
is Russia alone that used its veto six
times to prevent the condemnation of
Assad's use of chemical weapons if
Russia have lived up to its commitment
there would be no chemical weapons in
Syria and we would not be here today the
United States estimates that Assad has
used chemical weapons in the Syrian war
at least 50 times since the world first
took notice in 2013 public estimates are
as high as 200 times we're again
confident that both Syria had
responsibility in this chemical weapons
attack but we also hold Russia
responsible for their failure to stop
chemical weapons attacks from taking
place Britain and France say they have
the evidence we have proved that last
week now nearly 10 days ago that
chemical weapons were used at least
chlorine and that they were used by
Bashar al-assad's regime the French
president called Russian President
Vladimir Putin today offering an olive
branch to return to a negotiated
settlement to end the Syrian civil war
but the Russian Foreign Minister doubled
down calling evidence of a chemical
attack a hoax even blaming the UK for
seeking to frame Assad in Russia down
their talks we have irrefutable evidence
that this was another staging which the
special services of a certain nation had
a hand in this a nation that was trying
hard to be in the front role of the
Russia phobic campaign which elicited a
spirited response from the British UN
Ambassador this is grotesque it's a
blatant lie it's some of the worst piece
of fake news we've yet seen from the
Russia propaganda machine
the USS Harry s Truman accompanied by
seven warships armed with hundreds of
Tomahawk missiles is still a week away
from the Mediterranean and has 45 strike
aircraft on board in addition to dozens
of helicopters the Pentagon has enough
assets in the region USS Donald cook in
the eastern Mediterranean along with two
US warships in the Red Sea as well as a
classified number of submarines the
French have a frigate armed with cruise
missiles in position the British have
Tornado jets in Cyprus as well as
submarines in the Mediterranean Russian
Admiral threatened to torpedo the USS
Donald cook if it fires on Syrian
targets
Russia has warships and likely
submarines in the Mediterranean the
Pentagon wants to know what is the
long-term strategy if ordered to carry
out a strike
right tense situation tonight Jennifer
Griffin at the Pentagon Jennifer thank
you